welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the spider-man no way home
trailer is an endless treasure trove of
intriguing detail that now that many of
us are able to see that salt and dr
strange's salt and pepper beard and a
big ass imax screen aspect ratio i have
spotted 12 new clues and easter eggs
many of which have completely changed
the way i am looking at this film so i'm
gonna break down all the new stuff i
found because i know you can't get
enough of this okay on the rooftop on
mj's new york post reading spider-man
and his fighter minions you can also see
the text at the bottom of the page his
hypnotic spider sense this actually
might be the first explicit mention of
spidey sense or spider sense in the mcu
one of his more somewhat downplayed
powers in the mcu compared to past
iterations of peter parker but in this
context spun as if peter parker had mind
control powers which he does not but he
does later let his guilt over
gaslighting mj cause him to tamper with
dr strange's spell i also think it's
worth noting peter's shoes he wears the
jordan 1 hyper crimsons here and for
most scenes in the trailer but in
specific other shots like when doctor
strange astral pushes his soul from his
spider-suited body and when he armors up
on the car he wears blue vans old
schools now sure a kid can have two
pairs of shoes but shawshank redemption
made me shoe paranoid and since peter in
those ladder scenes is wearing the same
outfit as tubby mcguire peter parker
from spider-man 3 his wardrobe could be
a hint to the way toby mcguire and
andrew garfield might appear in this
film as souls swapping into different
spider bodies now a little detail but a
fun one as peter swings mj through times
square she covers his eyes with her hand
and with her hair so that they almost
smack into one of those screens showing
his face from j jonah jameson's daily
bugle broadcast but then one big
confirmation from this imax cut when
peter gets interrogated by the
department of damage control agents the
hairy set of arms who slams case files
in front of peter that some thought was
charlie cox matt murdock but i didn't
think so we can now see this guy's face
and it is definitely not charlie cox in
fact it's the same actor who plays the
bearded dodc agent he's just taken off
his jacket and rolled up his sleeves now
this does not rule out charlie cox from
cameo and elsewhere in the film this
just is not him here then in mj's room i
pointed out that drawing of coach wilson
that she drew back in spider-man
homecoming as part of her collection of
people in crisis but also from that
collection is a sketch of peter with a
dark cloud over his head kind of like
the curse that follows him in this movie
and literally takes the form of a
lightning storm with attacks from
elektro then on to the sanctum sanctorum
when wang opens the portal to leave he
is definitely headed to camara taj by
the way pointed this out before but yeah
that stone structure is the same one
that is in the commentary training yard
he's not on his way to macau to spar
with abomination and chongqi or to that
holding facility that abomination was in
but i do like some nice vfx details the
sparks from the portal bounce on the
surfaces it's really cool to see all the
vfx interacting with the real world and
behind doctor strange that vase above
the fireplace has begun to thaw out from
the heat just showing that whatever
caused this sanctum to freeze over it's
not a permanent curse it really does
seem like a freak spell gone awry that
might connect with a theory that i have
later on in this video hey but real
quick you know what's more fun than
blowing up weaponized robots blowing
them up with your friends mech arena is
a tactical shooter that lets you play in
fun two verses two or five versus five
matches and tournaments with your
friends there are a ton of cool mechs to
pick from one i really like is the
guardian he is slow and plotting but
homeboy packs a really big punch and can
shut down opponent's skills and then on
the opposite end of that spectrum is
shadow he's super fast and elusive but
has a ninja-like stealth ability to
sneak around enemies there's just so
many options in this game from which
mechs to use to how you gear them to
what skins you have on them no matter
how you play it's fun to mix it up and
blow some stuff up and there are a load
of events happening in game this month
where you can get a bunch of awesome
weapons including the new disc launcher
there's also a ton of halloween events
to take part in and halloween skins to
win don't want to miss out on the great
login rewards program it's completely
free to play on android and ios right
now and you can use our link or scan the
qr code to get one forest digital skin
200 acorns and 10 000 credits to help
kick-start your game and if you're quick
you can add us as friends and we can
play some matches together so don't wait
around when strange begins to spell i
did point out before how his bowl
contains these animal figurines like an
elephant a ram and then either an owl or
a lion but a new detail as the spell
progresses apparently there is a new
figurine that gets added to this a stout
four-legged figure that at first i
thought could be a dijiang like morris
from shanxi but looking at it from a
different angle it does seem to have a
longer snout that does make it look like
an alligator gator loki confirmed
there's also a long bird feather on the
rim over on the right there i wonder if
each of these animal representations
could link with the villains that get
sucked into this reality since there
seemed to be about five or six of them
then when doctor strange conjures his
runic bands at one point he zips a piece
of magic back into his hand and reads
the runes on it as if he is checking to
see if this is a correct reality script
he wants to use to paper over peter's
current condition kind of the way he who
remains read his sacred timeline like a
script now famously director john watts
loves to hide easter eggs in the license
plates of his spider-man movies in my
experience really the only marvel
director who actually does this because
otherwise really any number you see on
screen can refer to any random comic
issue but watts is one who actually is
deliberate about it and in a shot of
peter in the iron spider armor on the
blue vw to the right the tag number is
1963-03 that is for the amazing
spider-man number three in the year 1963
the famous issue with spider-man first
base doctor octopus in the comics as
peter is doing in this scene that's not
all folks on the black kia behind peter
the tag number is mtu 2174 which struck
my eye because in spider-man far from
home mtu was used on another license
plate reference and it stands for marvel
team up number 21 in 1974 in which
spider-man teams up with dr strange it's
an interesting storyline because an old
sorcerer named zandu hypnotizes peter
into stealing the crystal cadavers from
the sanctum and uses that crystal to
regenerate the wand of watum to
resurrect his wife zanu ends up
transporting peter and strange into
another dimension where he marionettes
them all together and strange gets out
of it by using a spell that allows peter
to fire mystical blasts from his hands
now of course the bigger comics parallel
for this movie is probably gonna be
spider-man one more day from 2007 and
it's follow-up story one moment in time
but there are definitely some parallels
with this marvel team-up story with
strange giving peter a new black and
gold suit in this movie that allows him
to swip magic from his hands and this
whole idea of characters being stuck
under hypnosis i just won't be surprised
if the reason strange so brazenly helps
peter with a dangerous spell is that he
could be under a kind of mind control if
not by someone like mephisto i'm not
always going to go there maybe the
scarlet witch as she tries to spin the
multiverse more and more out of control
in search of her kids in fact wanda's
control over strange could be why the
sanctum is frozen to begin with now
something else is going on with this
shot of peter looking at the woman in
the car but she's actually not just any
extra or a placeholder asset masking
anything this is actress paula newsom
from csi vegas and barry on hbo she's
likely playing some bigger role in the
story maybe a shield or dodc agent or
the d.a legally targeting peter now for
this last point i'm going to discuss
some new stuff we learned in the
post-credits scene of venom let there be
carnage so if you have not seen that
movie yet spoiler warning actually feel
free to stop watching now okay the venom
carnage post-credits scene transported
venom to the mcu through a kind of
reality warp and he's now reacting to
the daily bugle broadcast about peter
parker and the big implication being
that venom might appear in spider-man no
way home so i wanted to re-examine that
shot of peter and what i assume is the
magical containment facility i actually
believe the green cube artifact that we
see in the trailer the moment when peter
spins around as something swipes at a
barrier separating them i said this was
the lizard rhys iphone's dr connors from
the 2012 amazing spider-man some others
are now making a case for venom but if
you look closely you can clearly see
this guy has a lizard tail switching
behind him venom has no tail however
venom could very well be the sixth
villain of the sinister six lineup and
or one who switches teams to side with
peter because something fishy is going
on with doctor strange folks and eddie's
hotel furniture checkerboard flipping
into a new reality just looks to me too
much like wanda maximoff jigsawing her
hex reality into existence as well as
her chaotically redecorating her living
spaces for me to rule her out as the one
pulling the strings of the guy that
darkhold just told her she's more
powerful than so doctor strange and
venom dock green goblin the others and
peter parker and his variants all could
be pawns of the scarlet witch's game as
we head into doctor strange's multiverse
of madness let me know your thoughts
down below and you can support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter eaboss
follow and subscribe to me rockstars
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you